hi in this video
i will talk about role of e protein in
the dengue virus infection cycle
so just a recap of
the infection infection cycle of dengue
virus
so dengue virus doesn't have any
particular receptor to dock in
it can dock into various type of
receptor for instance here it
get associated with
mannose receptor
or mr
so you can see
after dengue virus
associated with mannose receptor
receptor mediated endocytosis
uh take place
so
here is the endocytotic vesicle
inside that
our dengue virus is there
now if this endocytotic vesicle
is going in its normal path then there
is a chance that dengue this endocytic
vesicle would fuse with lysosome and the
dengue virus would die so dengue virus
devised a technique so that it could
fuse with the
endocytic vesicle and it can release the
content it can release its content that
means it's genetic material which is a
plus strand rna
into the cytoplasm
and after the after it
releases its blast and single strand
rna one side the rna replicates to form
new genome for new progeny viruses
on the other hand from the plaster and
ssrna
the proteins are made into the er
and the whole packaging of the virus is
done and the virus is released and ready
to infect another
particular cell
so we would focus on
this region
where
the dengue virus would fuse with the
endocytotic vesicle
and
after fusing it would release its
genetic material into the cytoplasm
in this respect a particular protein
helps that i have earlier mentioned that
protein is
viral e protein let's see it in details
so if you zoom in this section we would
find that
here is our dengue virus
you can see in the dengue virus it has
the
rna genome it has the e protein and it
has
a c protein which is a matrix protein
and inside
and this is the whole
endocytic vesicle and this is the
receptor by which the dengue virus
initially docked and now what happened
in a series of reaction i would show how
the dengue virus would
dock with the particular membrane and
fuse these two membrane to release its
genomic material into the cytoplasm
so first this is the structure of the c
protein basically you can see there are
three domains one represented in red red
another in black and another in blue
so
inside the endocytic vesicle the ph
falls below 7 that means in an acidic
condition so in acidic condition what
happens there is a conformational change
there is a conformational change and due
to this conformational change
this upper domain the head domain of
this particular e protein actually get
initial get associated with the
membrane of the vesicle
and now
the full assembly you can see
here
after this assembly
what happens there is further
conformational change in this
transmembrane region
which pulls these two particular
membrane towards each other this pulls
this particular two membrane towards
each other
it pulls them further
and when you pull
then further what happens ultimately is
two membranes fuse with each other and
after that
here
the viral genome is there and it could
be easily released into the cytoplasm
and after it is released in the
cytoplasm
it could do its function
it could transcribe
the g the proteins that are necessary
for the viral assembly and it could
replicate its genome and this is how the
tengu viral e protein is very essential
for its infection cycle i hope you
enjoyed this video if you like my video
give it a quick thumbs up don't forget
to subscribe and please leave your
comments below thank you